Kiriko to warm greetings to everyone in
our community firstly I want to
acknowledge that for many of you it's
been a difficult week I know there's
been a high level of uncertainty and
things are changing on an almost daily
basis I need to reassure you that the
council was working extremely hard to
support our community and ensure all
essential services that's water
roading recycling and rubbish will
continue to operate smoothly through
this difficult time we've followed
Ministry of Health guidelines and shut
all counts or building and facilities in
order to protect our residents we are
closely following the situation and as
soon as it's possible to reopen our
facilities we will do so in the meantime
we're adapting and finding ways for
people to access council services
remotely staff from departments such as
aquatic facilities are being redeployed
to assist our community and other areas
we're it safe to do so our libraries
already offer a great range of digital
services you can access from home you
can contact our customer services by
email phone Facebook snap send and solve
as much as possible we'll be carrying
out our normal activities such as dog
registrations limbs and animal
management we have streamlined our
council decision-making and formed a
covert 19 response committee made up of
councillors so our council can quickly
adapt to any changes that may arise our
councillors are at this moment taking
another look through our budgets in the
projects we had planned for the coming
year it is important that our
infrastructure is maintained that we
support our local contractors and that
we are keep planning for future growth
however there may be other spending that
can be deferred until the situation is
behind us I encourage you to listen and
follow the advice
from the government remain calm
look after one another and when the
restrictions ease support our local
businesses as much as you can
our community is strong and resilient
our pandemic plans are up to date and
civil defense are ready to activate if
needed we have been through hard times
before and together united we will beat
this virus
you